so when you see a cat there is no cat
signal flowing down a single connection
and activating a single cat neuron
instead the idea of a cat takes the form
of a unique group of neurons which
activate at the same time this is known
as a distributed
representation another example of a
distributed representation is a musical
chord it's a group of notes which are
activated at the same time where notes
are like neurons and these unique groups
of neurons trigger different mental feel
feelings in our
minds to get a sense of what I mean by
mental feeling take a look at this image
it contains two different things
depending on your interpretation you can
actually feel the flip or clunk
happening in your mind as it toggles
back and forth between these two
different interpretations it is a result
of different neuron activations in the
deeper layers of your
mind